I mentioned this earlier in the show
that it's a cool total coincidence that
you are here on the same night as your
former co-star in the office Angela
Kinsey
it's a weird coming together is it weird
for you that she's on the same show it's
a little strange seeing her backstage I
haven't seen her in like a year we text
a lot but I haven't seen her in a little
bit but there's gonna be a little mini
office reunion right here potential yes
lately act tonight
yeah that's weed you don't have the
imagination to think of something like
this Yeah right
we didn't we realize it like an hour ago
otherwise you would have promoted it in
some way shape or form we don't throw
things no no we like to kind of here we
kind of like to fly under the radar or
submarine we we used to have a sign
spinner but yeah it's great you know a
little office reunion but you know
office fans I tell you Conan they I love
them they're the best and they are the
worst too because this whole thing with
Angela is like if I tweet out or
Instagram a picture of like me and my
wife at the comments it's the same
comments like what about Angela won't
Angela be jealous is that that doesn't
look like Angela and it's like guys guys
stop it
terrible office jokes like if I if I
tweet about a meal that I had they're
like did you have beets where they're
beets in it I hope there were beets in
it that's like enough already I love you
but that is just terrible yeah yeah yeah
so we have a whole truckload of beets
for you backstage
we just do
you know the show ended like four years
ago he's a fictional character he was a
beet farmer he was in love with Angela
it's done it's done sorry guys right
right yeah you never look at that you
just told him you just told them there's
no Santa you son of a [ __ ]
you